diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit der
camembert cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Musik]
und wie schaut sie war aber nicht so
sagte you na park auf dem platz ganz
knapp 100 rücken der legende große
traten durch
naja und abzüglich
böse schon super zu gering sei
der hohe franken um panikmache auf
dingen bei gestiegen also wenn man von
der aufräumt
die person die ihnen die ruhe schlafen
auf der abacho richtung wald hat merck
habe mich bemüht und dem augenblick
bewusst forstlich als problem
bitte liebe und sein schwager im süchtig
sind habe ich auch sagt es nämlich
zerstört da games bereits absolute
minimum extrem 280 kilo wäsche wuschen
existiert hat und nicht das problem
und ihr absoluter annika beschloss dass
wir etwas der versuchte die übersetzung
[Musik]
online-gaming ein volkssport der alle
rekorde bricht
auch in der schweiz sind drei von vier
jugendlichen mehr als eine stunde
täglich an gängen
zwar sollen computerspiele auf viele
gehirnaktivitäten positive effekte haben
aber vor kurzem hat die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who den
sucht erstmals als neues krankheitsbild
klassifiziert gaming disorder zu deutsch
spiel störung
[Musik]
auch der 30-jährige libyen der seinen
vollen namen nicht nennen möchte hat
viele jahre gebraucht um sich endlich
eingestehen zu können dass er
computerspielsüchtig ist er hat bereits
mehrere anläufe unternommen seine spiel
störungen zu überwinden
jeder rückschlag wirft die frage auf ob
seine game sucht überhaupt heilbar ist
das versucht liebi nun in einer
entzugsklinik herauszufinden
solide körper wurden herausgeschleudert
das wurde nicht mit denen das ich spüre
dass ich später sie jetzt im hirn
dann kommt man ja wieder vergangen
nachdem liebe als zeuge jene schweren
unfalls an einer viehschau seine eigene
gefühllosigkeit registriert hatte wenn
ein steiniger weg
unter der anleitung der psychologin
angelika schneider versucht er mittels
verschiedener techniken seine
selbstbehandlung zu trainieren
ich habe dieses buch probiert aber
vielleicht meine sachen cannabis bringt
und sein dass das mit dem königstuhl
brauchen kann liebe keine gefühle
wahrnehmen hängt dieses defizit mit
seiner game sucht zusammen
wenn ja wo liegen die ursachen davon
und wann hat das alles begonnen
[Musik]
in new york city hat ist erst zwölf jk
erzieherisch baltischen ornik sehe ich
es nochmals rink sie mit älteren
schwester ich habe schon relativ passend
sind extrem wirtschaft
er hat mich so mag es schon probiert des
mittellands nach einem biss spieler bis
bauer
[Musik]
und die große terrasse meißenheimer
pflanzgarten fragt york eine zulage wie
die kosmische augenblick
es wird miteinander ganz schön
[Musik]
mit dem mini vater jede schwester als
extrem flüssig wie vater pedantisch also
es ist nicht ganz so wichtig wie ein
bleistift und lineal ausgerichtet hat
auch cluster sowas fleißig gearbeitet
wie ich also aufgrund gesagt ich bin ein
absoluter also nach rom berufen jung bei
den usa eine selbständige habe der
verkäufer schuld schulbücher oder 50
das ist bisweilen eine dkw
nachvollziehen wie vater eines extrem
sportlich gesehen besser trainiert und
sich unsportlich
er schlafe oder warmduscher zentraler
grund liegt dazu schließt partner
geführt
hani
die pc flüchten ein gamer und je mehr
abgesondert und abgeschottet hat es doch
neben ihr freund ein anderes vorhaben
[Musik]
das deutsche online wachsen
ein großteil davon macht das ist monster
und für sie ganz so lustig das leben in
münster für die foto gesamten
erfahrungen in moskau erreicht großteil
vom rights in gfk richter verteilen oder
relativ geradlinig
man weiß ja mit 1001 nacht gibt es das
muss man machen diesen gegner das als
belohnung
richtig aber die halle durch gewusst was
sie dort machen
tony hayward und elektroniker wenn jetzt
etwas machen wäre die andere übt auf
viele jugendliche haben sich beim gehen
an eine unmittelbare belohnung gewöhnt
während es im realen leben groß strecken
gibt und der erfolg ungewiss ist
ja mein vater mit privatjet es nicht so
war sie hatte praktisch mir sehr leid
und macht der drei großen ganze letzte
was ich so war es für ihn auch politisch
abhängig nach dem motto das auge schaut
im schnitt war spox sowieso nicht
manche eltern versuchen ihren kindern
jede frustration zu ersparen
bei libri war es offenbar genau um
wieder
trotzdem enttäuschte liebe die hohen
beruflichen erwartungen seiner eltern
das dach ist die ehemalige ober doch
nicht machen
lebensmitteltechniker richtig bock
fahrer deren großen ganzen burkhard
erste planet beruf.de gestellte
geschlachtet achse oder schlachter und
vielfach hatte wollte jetzt nicht
wirklich denn einfach eine gangart ab ca
und bei der heim-wm gamer im fernsehen
was man auch ganz deutlich sagen es ist
nach immer mehr umworben worden
und das hat der heime zu weiteren
konflikten geführt
da bin ich hoch und höher im bus herum
desto mehr bruchstraße zusammen
nach dem motto mehr platz für die 20
moskau wieder schlafen
die fabrik hat ina müller und ich spürte
mit dem entsprachen aufgabe so verkürzte
wieder konfliktpunkt worte und das
ambiente wie attraktive pizzen im
kühlschrank einfach dass es da mach ich
sie nicht
ich weiß nichts weiter die achse waren
die nacht wieder aktiv für pkw vor
kurzem wieder wochen die steuerkraft
wenige wochen oder so gelten die chance
ist da gegangen
für den knapp 17 jährigen liebe muss die
game welt äußerst hilfreich gewesen sein
um seine verstoßung von zu hause einfach
wegstecken zu können
bewohner vor kraft bin ich prima tanks
sie als tank miteinander bietet euch mal
panzer und sorgt dafür dass schadens
machen weiter machen das ist albumcover
werden schadens machen trägt auch eine
tischdecke wandertag vielleicht steckt
aber nicht viel gemacht
gute frage wenn wir einigermaßen gut
gemacht
gruppe 2 auf das funktioniert gut getan
liebe findet eine virtuelle
ersatzfamilie im realen leben kommt da
vorerst bei einem arbeitskollegen unter
die berufslehre bringt er trotz allem zu
ende findet aber anschließend keinen job
ab da ist er nur noch am gamen und ich
gern meter hat er echt prima zwei
heutige tag ist ein tisch möglich nur am
bildschirm herr focus relativ
unwahrscheinlich so völlig der
rückblende vita gemacht zu sein gräflich
wie die alle flaschen trinken links
haben in der bis auf den tisch irgendwie
scheine tisch müssen ersetzen
und da ist einfach chipsparte geben im
stuhl beim abbremsen
das ist nun mal so haben wir seiner
baracke und ja wenn der abend die
sympathisch ist das sehr unterhaltsame
braucht auch mal uns wo sie da und hat
noch nicht genug
[Musik]
in der regel nicht ganz freiwillig sind
einfach vom pc auf fordern ihre
verbündeten im schlaf
das richtige nicht auf eurem pc zu einem
gewissen maße spielfigur spielfigur
hatte die ganze problem moneypenny
darüber richtig sehen können welche auch
andere länder sind wichtige
abnehmerländer game süchtige sind sozial
weit weniger auffällig als drogen- oder
alkoholabhängige
oft wissen nur eltern oder mitbewohner
um den spielsüchtigen hinter seinem wc
doch bei liebi wir hatten die probleme
eines tages aktenkundig wenn ich mit den
kollegen manchmal die zeit für sozialen
ja jetzt druck machen kollegen
hauptsächlich für euch dem gerät kann
man das gold und die situation ist also
ich weiß dass er stets nur so viel
abgeschaut habe kabul ich komm untergang
des rieses sie wurde auch schon
irgendwas nicht wieder so schnell wie
möglich und so hat sich der als relativ
groß
fast vier jahre lang kam der wg kollege
von libby für dessen miete und
lebenshaltungskosten auf einestages
kündigt er die gemeinsame wohnung
sozialdienste gaga zum telefonieren für
übergangslösungen
so bin jetzt immer so wieder gelandet
ursprünglich war das nochmal
kukksi die ständig mehr und mehr auf
einfach irgendwas findet sie
es ist ein vorurteil zu glauben dass er
mal weniger kommunikativ sind als andere
menschen aber ihr spektrum im sozialen
austausch ist sehr eingeschränkt
[Musik]
der bereich um schließlich im teamspeak
kommuniziert haben stimmt mich gehst
nicht ganz an verbaler nicht stattfinden
nicht gar als potenz x serie
richtige realer werden schon im gerade
tatzeit lohnarbeit rinke vom
sozialdienst ende zu entscheiden so
sagen beschäftigungsstruktur gott wieder
zur hochburg von der tagesstruktur und
auch eine gewisse zeit ist aber die
entweder dazu oh das tut zum abbruch tue
ich das um maschinen ist sich nun
gemeldet hat um ihn ohne möglichkeit
beim organ des medien sind für begangen
durch im hotelzimmer kubicki
eine muse gar schaut sind deine chance
nach motto strebe eine halbe leichter
bis zum neckar ist man sich bewusst
gesegnet bis auf die gegend bis auf
nicht gut aber wirklich auch eine sahara
stadtgründer
es sind den hang fahren zum hotel und
klopfen und meine kollegen tausendmal
und schrittmacher böse wirklich sehr
groß
fruchtfliegen geflogen
mehr krieg sie das im lebensmittellabor
domenico vergammelt sind sich aus
abdunkelt 710 meter feinstem stoff blogs
und den mann getroffen schlaf ist
relativ gute grafik sie und liefert das
system wieder schöner anblick die
wohnzimmer schlussendlich den ausschlag
gab in die punkte das bedeutet wir den
braucht er jetzt sogar bietet
fünf jahre ist es her dass lewis
sozialarbeiterin einen richtungswechsel
initiiert liebe sollte in ein neues
umfeld kommen in eine gastfamilie
betreut vom projekt ab
[Musik]
mit 24 kommt libyen nach aeschlen im
kanton bern wo er bis heute auf dem
google hof bei der familie häuser gut
die erste sirene nach und bund also sehr
großer spaß zur verkäuferin und den 103
20 uhr an live stream und alles seinen
frisch installiert
ich hoffe kulturschock honeycomb nur der
erste sturm rücken
das ist ja nicht ständig mit dem konzept
brachte
ja das fest rückt eine kandidatur gehabt
die einfache regel überhaupt das gilt es
den ball aber wenn sie größer als alle
events einmal hallo und bänke mit hand
also immer gar zum teil mit dreckigen
handeln eine kur mit strache nicht
unbedingt überlegen
ökologie gesicht sprach und nach unten
das ist nicht
[Musik]
nach jahren der vereinzelung plötzlich
täglich umgeben von einer sechsköpfigen
familie für liebe eine herausforderung
aber die chemie stimmt auch die kinder
mögen ihn gerne liebe selbst muss sich
den neuen umständen zunächst einmal
körperlich anpassen so durch wie
spaziergang wollten und haben auch im
bund wieder raus er schreit ich bin oben
noch auch und also völlig außer atem des
komponisten vergeben
das neue klima besser als eine relativ
zügig angefangen hat durch die
vermietung macht täuschen lassen andere
waldbesucher
wenn nicht ist einfach fällig theresa
software factory der regel nur die
stimmung ist auch schon hoch material
ada
[Musik]
schafft es libyen nach den vielen jahren
im virtuellen kosmos seine
aufmerksamkeit wieder aufs reale leben
zu lenken
eben noch was machen das system aber ins
studio und betrieben steht das wasser
durch gar nie erklärt mir dass man sagt
der richtigen frau mit juni glücklich
dass ich das lachen
seit seinem schlüssel erlebnisse auf der
viehschau weiß liebi dass ihm der zugang
zu den eigenen gefühlen fährt er glaubt
dass ihnen diese erkenntnis der heilung
seiner game sucht entscheidend näher
gebracht hat
und jörg farr geheime krieg emotional
sozialstaat blieben gut das waren ich
dann selber nicht mehr aufgabe auch in
alltäglichen situationen weiß für die
anfänglich schwierig nicht vor seinen
gefühlen davonzulaufen
das praktikum für das praktikum
und ich gemerkt dass ich noch ganz viele
gesichter aber nicht stimmt dass ich ein
problem löse mich wieder in ruhe den
konflikt geworden nicht klar
[Musik]
schauspielerisch großen halle stand
einfach nicht
fords machen als nukleare statt flüchten
vor schwierigen situationen alles
vermeiden was innerliches unbehagen oder
überhaupt eine gefühlsregung hervorrufen
könnte diese muster scheinen sich levy
seit seiner jugend regelrecht
eingebrannt zu haben
oder hat umgekehrt erst die sucht solche
verhaltensmuster geprägt mit anderen
worten ist die game sucht das
grundproblem oder ist sie bloß eine
reaktion auf andere schwierigkeiten
[Musik]
repro
das ist immer ganz viel zu spannend ob
es auch bei sauberen sports machen halt
mit einer zur geschichte körper
[Musik]
mit denen kontaktlos in regem kontakt
für ihn ist natürlich sehr wichtig
9 urhg mal wenn es noch so gut
das brauchte der liebe ganz fest die
männliche bezugsperson für den großen
und ganzen trocken
mehr aus familie sie bezugs familie
das braucht er das regen wohne irgendwo
es erfordere
das braucht auge schon wichtig
es läuft ja auch relativ das buch
wirklich intensiv
die große frage und die gegen sucht hat
sich libyen gesunden umfeld davon
befreien können ist das verlangen nach
ablenkung und verdrängung verschwunden
ich kann mir immer noch satter auf das
haltende gehörte weniger zumindest
wahrscheinlich ja
sie vertrieb jetzt genug der
pressestunde heute schon im 8er
vernünftigen umgang vernünftiges maß
offiziell wisse das game mit amoled bist
vormonate teile ganz frisch online
geschichten lassen
tierversuche ist nicht konnte
mit der situation damals 17 euro durch
das wlan oder erschienen ist
womit ich das gewusst aber etwas weniger
bewiesen
bis morgens bewusstsein kritisch über
die augen langsam ist ganz weg gab es 73
fluchtmöglichkeiten heißt konnte
bestehen
ja also selbe sache beschönigen nach dem
motto ich bin eine wasserrutsche 38
meter das 2 2 1 und ist das schlimm habe
ja vielleicht doch nicht so tragisch und
sein wie jetzt ist zwar halbstock sie
ist immer noch besser als fünf stunden
nicht weil es falsch gemacht hat
das ist eine relativ 44 grad einige
automatismus
wenn man meistens schon praxis studie
ortet eine ganz viel haben also sind die
finanzen gesellschaftlich engagiert die
samariter für ein outdoor vermieter
wiederum vermuten baumann vorjahr
seit ein paar monaten besucht libyen nun
wöchentlich in der klinik sehr hoffen
eine neu gegründete selbsthilfegruppe
für online-sucht
parallel dazu dass er es machen
ein problem das auch heimlich noch nicht
verkauft das aufbauen womit das ipad ist
ein mix ist auch das problem ist einfach
nur riesig
sind wie stand im bordprogramm ist ein
wenig steil oder sagt denn dass ich das
nicht könnte man das nicht sogar positiv
sehen endlich kommen gefühle hoch und
werden für liebi wahrnehmbar
doch dann kommt ihm seine es sucht
wieder in die quere
in der speisekammer fehlen eines tages
wirst die für den verkauf bestimmt waren
für die familie reusser ist nun klar
dieses ereignis muss für levy
konsequenzen haben
standort denker der monate ohne internet
ende nicht für euch ist klar machen
unter anderem macht das verantwortliche
denken das wird nötig ist und damit
mache diskrete silberwald gebiet der usa
gastfamilie darüber diskutiert ob ihren
unterricht für den sozialbereich und
ihre gibt der druck dass sich wenig
verändert
vor allem im online sucht das online
großer teller vor sich dieses modell für
kleinere studios vergaß los ist ob der
therapie
erwartet aber ich spüre ich spüre es
nicht oder habe ich mit kanal onyx
wunsch im film aber wir haben wie echte
problem stelle also das ganze wieder
vorbei
damit die dreharbeiten rütteln auf aber
gleichzeitig steht der bus diebstahl im
raum
sandra eiser pocht darauf dass liebi
diesem thema nicht aus wenn du geschützt
das müsse auch dass miro dass das nein
das kann ich dir nicht sagen
die schlussfolgerung dass jetzt das klar
ich habe mit vertretern von maxi das mit
outlook struktur nicht mehr zum leben zu
nehmen
also alles jeder aber ist die sahara
credit suisse hat und der umgebung
aber das muss konsequent wäre ehrlich es
ist nicht fünf vor zwölf
im moment ist nichts passiert
[Musik]
ich bejahe ambulante zahlen stellte
gruppe hoch sind es heute sei es ruhig
habe ich selber mache ich mache das sei
was hart macht entschuldigen
abgeschotteten ja also sein wird ist
wahrscheinlich nicht packen
[Musik]
sie hoffe dass mir erwartet weiß ich
nicht was ich mir auf wenn irgendeine
vergangenheit vernünftig abschließen so
dass es nicht wieder so ist das wenn
imperial kratzt wird dasselbe schon
merken dass sie es wirklich woche wird
es wieder beachten und zerstören da gmbh
einfach nur zu nehmen wissen mitnehmen
da muss ein ansatz sein
seitdem immer noch erst im wasser statt
seiner schwäche und dass sie andere
liegt und auf die andere seite
[Musik]
braucht
ich brauche das
[Musik]
psychologisch ist das ein problem für
den 20
komisch
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von bmw
genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
bergmann der tübinger genuss seit 1922